quelques mots des circonstances
personnelles m'ont tenu écarté de
l'hémicycle hier à l'occasion de votre
intervention
s'agissant de la demande de minutes de
silence de ma collègue caroline fiat et
vous avez exciper président du fait qu'
il n'appartenait pas à chacun
d'improviser des minutes de silence
je voulais vous l'avait interdite je
voudrais vous rappeler que sous votre
propre présidence j'ai moi même décidé
de consacrer une minute de mon temps de
parole à une minute de silence à la
mémoire des gilets jaunes qui avaient
péri dans des accidents de circulation
au début de ce mouvement
c'est pourquoi je voudrais vous dire
amicalement mais solennellement la
désapprobation la plus vive notre groupe
et des personnels concernés à l'égard de
votre décision